양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Matus이고, IBM
Quantum에서 교육 기술 총괄을 맡고 있어요. 이번 강의는 시리즈의 12번째 수업이고, 일반적인
양자 정보 공식화를 다루는 세 번째 단원의 마지막 수업이에요. 이 수업은 양자 정보의 핵심 개념인
양자 상태의 정화(purification)를 중심으로 다뤄요. 어떤 밀도 행렬로 표현된 양자 상태의 정화란
더 큰 복합 시스템의 순수 상태로, 나머지 복합 시스템을
버리거나 추적 소거(trace out)했을 때 원래 상태가 남는 거예요. 모든 밀도 행렬은 정화를 가지고 있고, 직관적인 수준에서 정화를 연구하면
양자 상태와 양자 정보 전반에 대해 많은 걸 배울 수 있어요.
순수 상태를 나타내는 양자 상태 벡터는 밀도 행렬보다 수학적으로 더 단순한 대상이에요. 그리고
상태의 정화를 생각하면, 임의의 양자 상태를 더 크지만
더 단순한 무언가의 일부로 볼 수 있어요. 또한 두 양자 상태 간의 Fidelity에 대해서도 이야기할 건데, 이건 두 상태의
유사성이나 겹침을 수치로 나타낸 값이에요. 특정 상태가 어떤
이상적인 상태와 얼마나 유사한지 측정하는 방법으로 자주 사용되죠. 특히 Fidelity의 정의와 기본 성질들을 살펴보고,
Fidelity가 정화와 어떻게 연결되는지 보게 될 거예요. 수업 개요를 먼저 살펴볼게요. 먼저 정화부터 시작하는데,
정의와 존재에 대한 간단한 증명을 다뤄요. 이를 통해 필요할 때 정화를 어떻게 찾는지 알 수 있죠. 그 다음엔 Schmid
분해라고 알려진 두 시스템의 양자 상태 벡터에 대해 다루고, Schmid 분해가 정화와 어떻게 관련되는지 살펴볼 거예요.
그 다음엔 같은 상태의 두 정화 사이에 존재하는 중요한 관계, 즉 유니터리
동치성(unitary equivalence of purifications)에 대해 다루고, 마지막으로 몇 가지 예제를 살펴볼 거예요. 그런 다음 Fidelity로 넘어가서
정의와 기본 성질들을 다룰 거예요. Fidelity를 측정과 연결하는 아주 유용한 사실인 gentle measurement Lemma에 대해서도 이야기하고,
마지막으로 수업을 마무리하면서 Fidelity와 정화 사이의 근본적인 관계를 확립하는 Uhlmann의 정리로 넘어갈 거예요.
정화의
정의부터 시작해 볼게요. 밀도
행렬로 표현된 상태의 정화란, 나머지
복합 시스템을 추적 소거했을 때 원래 상태가 남는 더 큰 복합 시스템의 순수 상태예요. 이걸 더 정확하게 수학적으로 표현하면
다음과 같아요. 시스템 X가 어떤 상태 ρ에 있다고 하면, 즉 ρ가 X의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이고,
S가 한 쌍의 시스템 XY의 양자 상태 벡터인데, y에서 순수 상태를 추적 소거했을 때
ρ가 남는다면, S를 ρ의 정화라고 해요. 물론 이름은 중요하지 않아요. 시스템과 상태의 이름은
마음대로 정할 수 있고, 시스템의 순서도 중요하지 않아요. 예를 들어
시스템 y가 오른쪽이 아닌 왼쪽에 있어도, 나머지가 모두 같다면 Ψ를 ρ의 정화라고 부를 수 있어요. 하지만
단순함을 위해 나머지 수업에서는 이 형태를 주로 유지할 거예요. 그리고 정의에 대해 처음으로 말할 건
정화는 항상 존재한다는 거예요. 모든 밀도 행렬 ρ에 대해, 더 정확히 말하면 모든
밀도 행렬 ρ는 정의에서 설명된 것처럼 정화를 가지는데, 시스템 y가 X만큼 크면 되는 거예요. 즉
y의 고전적 상태 수가 X 이상이면 돼요. 정화의 개념과
정화가 항상 존재한다는 사실은 매우 중요하고, 양자 정보를 아름답게 만드는 요소이기도 해요. 이 수업이 끝날 때쯤엔
그 사실을 납득시킬 수 있으면 좋겠어요. 이제 모든 밀도 행렬이 정화를 가진다는 걸 증명해 볼게요. 그 과정에서
필요할 때 정화를 어떻게 구하는지도 알 수 있어요. 정화의 정의에서와 마찬가지로
X가 시스템이고 ρ가 X의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이라고 가정해 볼게요.
이제 화면에 표시된 것처럼 ρ를 순수 상태들의 볼록 조합(convex combination)으로 표현한다고 생각해 봐요.
즉, 양의 정수 n을 선택하면 확률 벡터 p₀부터 p_과 양자
상태 벡터 ψ₀부터 ψ_이 있고, 확률로 가중된 해당 순수 상태들을 평균하면
ρ를 얻을 수 있어요. 예를 들어 스펙트럼 정리를 사용해서 이런 표현을 구할 수 있고, 그렇게 하면
n을 X의 고전적 상태 수로 설정할 수 있어요. 사실 n을 ρ의 랭크로 설정할 수 있는데, 이는
각 고유값의 중복도만큼 세어서 ρ의 영이 아닌 고유값의 개수와 같고,
X의 고전적 상태 수보다 크지 않지만 더 작을 수도 있어요. 반면에
ρ의 스펙트럼 분해가 아니어도 괜찮고, 이 양자 상태 벡터들이 직교할 필요도 없어요. 예를 들어 이런 형태의 ρ 표현은
다 괜찮아요. 그리고 ρ의 정화가 여기 있어요. 합산은
ρ 표현에서와 같은 값들에 걸쳐 있고, 합산 안에서는 확률의 제곱근을 F_a에 곱하고
|k_a⟩와 텐서 곱을 해요. 여기서 0부터 n-1까지가 두 번째 시스템 y의 고전적 상태라고 가정하고 있어요.
그래서 S가 정의에서처럼 쌍 XY의 양자 상태 벡터가 되는 거예요. 이 표현에서 Y의 표준 기저 상태를 사용할 필요는
사실 없어요. |k₀⟩부터 |k_⟩ 대신에 원한다면 임의의 정규 직교 집합을
대입할 수 있어요. 이제 y에 대한 부분 추적(partial trace)을 계산해서 이것이 실제로
정화인지 확인할 수 있어요. 부분 추적을 수행해서 얻는 상태의 표현이 여기 있어요.
⟨k_a|k_b⟩의 추적 값은 a와 b가 같으면 1, 다르면 0이에요. 그래서 표현이
원래 ρ 표현으로 단순화되고, 아주 간단하죠. 따라서 정화를 구하는 건 매우 쉬워요.
Y의 고전적 상태가 충분하거나, 대안적으로 사용할 수 있는 충분히 큰 정규 직교 집합이 있으면
|k₀⟩부터 |k_⟩ 대신 사용할 수 있어요. 그런데
Y의 고전적 상태 수가 ρ의 랭크보다 작으면 정화가 존재하지 않아요. 원하시면
직접 생각해 보세요. 예제를 살펴볼게요.
밀도 행렬 수업에서 여러 번 봤던 밀도 행렬을 생각해 봐요. 여기에 이
밀도 행렬을 순수 상태들의 볼록 조합으로 표현한 게 있어요. 스펙트럼 분해는 아니지만
상관없어요. 거의 아무 노력 없이 이 레시피를 따라서 상태의 정화를
바로 쓸 수 있어요. 이게 이 밀도 행렬의 유일한 정화는 아니에요. 정화는 유일하지 않지만 괜찮아요.
정의에서 유일성에 대한 언급은 없어요. 사실 같은 상태의 서로 다른 정화들 사이에는 매우 흥미로운 관계가 있는데,
수업 뒤에서 조금 더 다룰 거예요. 다음으로 Schmid 분해를 살펴볼 건데, 이건 이중 분할 양자 상태 벡터를
곧 설명할 특정 형태로 표현한 거예요. Erhard
Schmidt의 이름을 딴 거고, Graham-Schmid 직교화 절차로 알려진 그 Schmidt와 같은 사람인데, Schmid 분해의 경우엔 사실
Schmidt의 이름을 붙이면 안 됐을 수도 있어요. 이건 수학적으로 행렬의 특이값 분해(singular value decomposition)라는 것과 동치인데, 여러 번
재발견된 것이기도 해요. 그런 일이 가끔 있죠. 어쨌든 Schmid 분해가 의미하는 게 뭔지 살펴볼게요.
한 쌍의 시스템 XY에 대한 임의의 양자 상태 벡터 s를 선택했을 때,
s를 특별한 형태로 쓰는 게 항상 가능해요. 화면에 나타난 것처럼
그 형태는, R은 양의 정수이고 p₀부터 p_은 양의 실수로
합쳐서 확률 벡터를 이루고, x₀부터 x_은 시스템 X에 해당하는 단위 벡터이고, y₀부터
y_은 시스템 y에 해당하는 단위 벡터예요. 이것만 봐서는 특별해 보이지 않을 수 있는데,
x₀부터 x_과 y₀부터 y_, 두 집합 모두
정규 직교(orthonormal)해야 한다는 걸 말씀드리면 달라질 거예요. 왜 특별하냐고요? 두 기저 중 하나를, 예를 들어
시스템 X에 해당하는 X 벡터들을 임의로 선택하면 항상 s를 이 형태로 표현할 수 있고, 그러면
Y 벡터들이 특정한 방식으로 결정되는 거예요. 사실 이건 표준 기저 측정을 분석할 때처럼 꽤 일상적으로 하는 작업인데,
일반적으로 X 벡터에 대해 정규 직교 기저를 선택하더라도 얻게 되는 Y 벡터들이 반드시 정규 직교가 되진 않아요. 마찬가지로
Y 벡터에 대해 정규 직교 기저를 선택하고 s를 이 형태로 표현하려 해도 가능하긴 하지만, X 벡터들이
반드시 정규 직교가 되지 않을 수 있어요. 그리고 마지막으로 두 시스템 모두에 대해 정규 직교 벡터를 선택하고
s를 이런 형태로 표현하려 하면 반드시 가능하지 않을 수 있는데, 교차항(cross terms)이 필요할 수도 있기 때문이에요. 하지만
이 합산에는 a라는 하나의 인덱스만 있어요. 그래서 이 형태가 특별한 건데, 주어진 단위 벡터 s를 이렇게 쓰는 건 항상 가능해요.
그리고 방법은 다음과 같아요.
먼저 두 시스템 중 하나의 축소 상태(reduced state)에 대한 스펙트럼 분해를 계산해요. 어느 것이든 상관없지만, 설명의 편의를 위해 X의 축소 상태를 살펴볼게요.
y를 추적 소거하는 건데, p₀부터 p_이 이 축소 상태 ρ의 고유값(eigenvalue)이고,
x₀부터 x_이 이 고유값에 해당하는 단위 고유 벡터(eigenvector)예요. 그리고
고유값이 0인 항들은 합산에 기여하지 않으므로 무시한다는 거 이해하시죠? 즉
p₀부터 p_은 모두 양의 실수이고, R은 중복도를 포함해서 센 영이 아닌
고유값의 개수인데, 이게 ρ의 랭크와 같아요. 그러면 p₀부터 p_과
x₀부터 x_을 얻을 수 있고, 남은 건 벡터 y₀부터 y_을 찾는 거예요.
이 시점에서 가능한 선택은 오직 하나예요. 벡터들이 유일하게 결정되고, 화면에 표시된 간단한 공식으로
쉽게 찾을 수 있어요. 놀라운 점은
이 방법으로 벡터를 정의하면 그 벡터들이 반드시 정규 직교가 된다는 거예요. 이렇게 Schmid 분해를 얻을 수 있어요. 이 영상에서는
그 이유를 증명하진 않겠지만, 그렇게 어렵지 않고 관심 있으시면 수업 자료를 참고하세요.
항상 그렇듯이 링크는 영상 설명에서 확인할 수 있어요. 예제로,
계속 되돌아오는 밀도 행렬 예제의 정화로 얻은
양자 상태 벡터를 생각해 볼게요. 0 상태와 플러스 상태가 정규 직교가 아니기 때문에 이건 Schmid 분해가 아니지만,
방금 설명한 절차로 찾을 수 있어요. 첫 번째 단계는 축소
상태 X의 스펙트럼 분해를 계산하는 건데, 그게 바로 같은 밀도 행렬 예제예요. 여기에
수업 9에서 봤던 스펙트럼 분해가 있어요. 그래서 화면에 표시된 대로
p₀, p₁, x₀, x₁을 선택해요. p₀과 p₁은 ρ의 고유값이고, x₀과 x₁은
해당 단위 고유 벡터예요. 그러면 남은 건 y₀과 y₁을 계산하는 것이고, 계산하면 y₀은 |+⟩,
y₁은 -1 × |-⟩가 나와요. 바로 보이는 건 아니고
실제로 계산을 해봐야 알 수 있는데, 그게 결과예요. 예상대로 계산을 올바르게 하면
두 벡터가 정규 직교가 돼요. 그러면 Schmid 분해를
얻게 되죠. Schmid 분해는 많은 상황에서 아주 유용하고, 곧 정화에 대해 무엇을 알려주는지 살펴볼 거예요.
정화는 유일하지 않아요. 밀도 행렬로 표현된 주어진 양자 상태는
사실 무한히 많은 정화를 가져요. 하지만 같은 상태의 두 정화 사이에는
항상 성립하는 밀접한 관계가 있고, 이걸 때때로 정화의 유니터리
동치성(unitary equivalence of purifications)이라고 해요. 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴볼게요. ρ를 시스템 X의 양자 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이라 하고,
같은 복합 시스템의 순수 상태인 그 상태의 임의의 두 정화가 있다고 가정해요.
구체적으로 s와 φ가
한 쌍의 시스템 XY의 양자 상태 벡터이고, 시스템 Y를 추적 소거했을 때
둘 다 ρ를 줘요. 정화의 유니터리 동치성이 말하는 건, 시스템 y에만 작용하여
s|ψ⟩를 |φ⟩로 변환하는 유니터리 연산 U가 반드시 존재한다는 거예요. 즉, 이것들이
ρ의 임의의 정화이고, 둘 다 ρ를 정화한다는 것과 같은 복합 시스템 XY의 상태라는 것 외에
아무것도 가정하지 않더라도,
y에 대한 유니터리 연산까지는 동치라는 거예요. 이게 왜 흥미롭고 어떤 의미를 가지는지 몇 가지 예제로 살펴볼 건데, 먼저
왜 성립하는지 알아볼게요. ρ의 스펙트럼 분해부터 시작할게요. ρ는
s|ψ⟩와 |φ⟩가 모두 정화하는 밀도 행렬이에요. Schmid 분해를 논의할 때처럼
영인 고유값에 해당하는 모든 항들을 버렸다고 가정할 거예요. 그래서 p₀부터 p_은
모두 양의 실수이고, x₀부터 x_은 ρ의 정규 직교 고유 벡터이고, R은
우연히도
ρ의 랭크예요. 그런데 여기서 잠깐, 이 시점에서 얼마나 자주 스펙트럼 정리를 활용하는지 주목해 보세요.
정말 엄청나게 유용한 도구이고 사실 이게 없으면 막막할 거예요. 어쨌든, ρ의 스펙트럼
분해를 얻었으니, 이전처럼 두 벡터의 Schmid 분해를 계산할 수 있어요. 그리고 거의
완전히 같을 거예요. 계수와 X 벡터들은 같아요. 두 벡터 모두에 대해 같은 축소 상태의 스펙트럼 분해에서 오기 때문이죠.
차이는 두 번째 시스템에 대해 다른 벡터를 얻을 수 있다는 거예요.
첫 번째 벡터인 s에 대해서는 벡터 집합 y₀부터 y_을 얻고, 두 번째 벡터인 f에 대해서는
다를 수 있는 z₀부터 z_이라고 부를 수 있는 집합을 얻어요. 그러면 이제 두 벡터의 Schmid 분해를 얻게 되는데,
두 번째 시스템의 벡터가 다를 수 있다는 것 외에는 매우 유사해 보여요. 하지만 이건
Schmid 분해이므로 두 집합 모두 정규 직교해요. 그러면 간단하게
각 a에 대해 y_a를 z_a로 보내는 유니터리 행렬 U를 선택할 수 있어요. 유니터리
연산은 사실 하나의 정규 직교 기저를 다른 기저로 변환하는 선형 사상과 동치예요. 그리고
이 두 집합이 Y에 해당하는 전체 공간에 걸쳐 있지 않더라도, 공교롭게도
Graham-Schmid 직교화 절차를 사용해서 두 집합 모두 정규 직교 기저로 확장할 수 있어요. 이렇게 정화의 유니터리
동치성이 증명돼요. 시리즈의 4번째 수업에서는 초고밀도 코딩(superdense coding) 프로토콜을 다뤘는데,
이건 하나의 ebit의 공유 얽힘을 대가로 하나의 qubit을 전송해서 두 개의 고전 비트를 수신자에게 전달할 수 있게 해주는 거예요.
이미 그 프로토콜을 알고 있다고 가정하고, 이 예제의 목적은 이게 정화의 유니터리 동치성과 어떻게 연결되는지
간단히 설명하는 거예요. 프로토콜이 어떻게 작동하는지 기억해 보면,
Alice와 Bob이 ebit, 즉 Φ⁺ Bell 상태를 공유해요. Alice는 전송하려는 두 비트에 따라 네 가지 Bell 상태 중 하나로
그 Bell 상태를 변환하고, 자신의
qubit을 Bob에게 보내면 Bob이 측정해서 어떤 Bell 상태인지 확인해요. 네 가지 Bell 상태 모두
Bob의 qubit에 대해 완전 혼합 상태라는 동일한 축소 상태를 줘요. 사실 그것만으로도
초고밀도 코딩이 가능하다는 결론을 내리기에 충분해요. 네 가지 Bell 상태 모두 완전 혼합 상태를 정화하므로, 정화의 유니터리
동치성에 의해 Alice가 자신의 qubit에 유니터리 연산을 적용해서 Φ⁺ Bell 상태를
다른 상태로 변환하는 것이 반드시 가능하다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 물론 실제로 작동하는 유니터리 연산을 찾는 건 어렵지 않고
매우 간단하지만, 유니터리 연산 자체를 생각하지 않고도 이게 가능하다는 결론에
도달할 수 있다는 건 흥미롭죠. 게다가
더 큰 시스템으로 초고밀도 코딩을 일반화하는 것도 가능하다는 걸 결론지을 수 있어요. Bob의 축소 상태로 완전 혼합 상태를 주도록 Bell 상태를 더 큰 시스템으로
일반화하는 방법이 있다면요. 그리고 실제로 그렇게 하는 여러 방법이 알려져 있어요.
정화의 유니터리 동치성이 시사하는 또 다른 맥락은 양자
암호학이에요. 가장 중요한 시사점 중 하나는, 비트 서약(bit commitment)이라는 암호학 기본 연산에 대해 무조건적으로 안전한 양자 프로토콜이 존재하지 않는다는 걸 배제한다는 거예요.
그럼 비트 서약이 뭔지 알아볼까요? 비트 서약은 암호학적 기본 연산의 예인데,
저수준 작업이나 절차로서 기본적인 기능을 제공하고, 이를 더 흥미로운 일을 위한
구성 요소로 사용할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 디지털 서명 체계를 만들거나
영지식 프로토콜(zero knowledge protocol)을 구축하는 데 활용할 수 있죠. 비트 서약의 경우, 기본 기능은 한
플레이어인 Alice가 자신이 선택한 이진 값을 두 번째 플레이어인 Bob에게 서약(commit)할 수 있지만, 그 선택은
공개하기로 선택하기 전까지는 숨겨져 있어야 해요. 비트 서약을 구현하는 프로토콜에는 두 가지 특성이 필요해요.
구속력이 있어야(binding) 하는데, 이는 Alice가 비트에 서약한 후 마음을 바꿀 수 없다는 거예요. 그리고
은폐(concealing)해야 하는데, 이는 Bob이 Alice가 공개하기로 선택하기 전까지 Alice의 비트를 알 수 없다는 거예요.
그래서 양자 정보를 사용해서 이 기본 연산을 구현할 수 있으면 꽤 좋겠지만,
추가적인 가정 없이는 양자 정보로 완벽하게 또는 완벽에 가깝게 구현하는 게 불가능하다고 밝혀졌어요.
정화의 유니터리 동치성이 보여주는 것은, 아주 높은 수준에서의 아이디어가
다음과 같다는 거예요. 비트 서약을 위한 양자 프로토콜이 존재한다면, 그 프로토콜의 소위 정화된 버전이 있어야 해요. Alice에게 시스템 A가 있고, Bob에게 시스템 B가 있고, 서약이 이루어진 후 Alice가 공개하기 전에
쌍 AB가 Alice가
서약한 비트에 따라 두 가지 순수 상태 |ψ₀⟩ 또는 |ψ₁⟩ 중 하나에 있다고 상상할 수 있어요.
프로토콜이 완벽하게 은폐한다면, Bob이 두
서약 사이의 차이를 구별할 수 없어야 해요. 따라서 두 가능성에 대해 Bob의 축소 상태가 같아야 해요. 하지만 그렇다면
정화의 유니터리 동치성에 의해 Alice가 A만으로 유니터리 연산을 적용해서 어느 하나를 다른 하나로
변환할 수 있다는 게 도출돼요. 그러면 프로토콜은 구속력이 완전히 없게 되죠. 세부 사항들을 생략했지만,
핵심은 정화의 유니터리 동치성이 추가적인 가정 없이 양자 정보로는 이 기본 연산을
신뢰성 있게 구현할 수 없다는 걸 알려준다는 거예요.
정화의 유니터리 동치성 시사점의 마지막 예제는 Houston-Joseph-Wouters 정리,
줄여서 HJW 정리라고 알려진 거예요. 정리 자체부터 살펴볼게요. 핵심 아이디어에 집중하기 위해
약간 단순화된 버전이에요. X와 Y가 시스템이고, F가
한 쌍 XY의 순수 상태를 나타내는 임의의 양자 상태 벡터라고 가정해요.
이제 시스템 X만의 축소 상태를 생각하고, 이 축소 상태를 화면에 표시된 것처럼
임의의 방식으로 순수 상태들의 볼록 조합으로 표현한다고 해봐요.
예를 들어, 이 표현에서 대문자 N, 즉 평균을 취하는 순수 상태의 수가
임의로 클 수 있고, X나 Y에 해당하는 공간의 차원보다 훨씬 클 수도 있어요.
그리고 정리가 말하는 건, 시스템 y에 N개의 결과를 갖는 측정이 반드시 존재해야 한다는 거예요.
시스템 Y가 측정될 때 다음이 일어나요. 각 측정 결과는
X의 축소 상태 표현에서 해당 확률과 정확히 같은 확률로
나타나요.
순수 상태들의 볼록 조합으로 표현했을 때, 두 번째로 특정 측정 결과를 얻었다는 조건 하에
X의 상태는 볼록 조합에서 해당하는 순수 상태가 돼요. 왜 흥미롭냐고요?
X의 축소 상태를 순수 상태들의 볼록 조합으로 생각하는 어떤 방식이든,
Y의 어떤 측정이 X의 축소 상태를 생각하는 이 방식을 사실상
현실로 만든다는 거예요. 놀라운 건, 상태 f가 먼저 선택되고
볼록 조합이 나중에 선택되더라도 이게 가능하다는 거예요. X의 축소 상태의 표현이기만 하면 정확히 이렇게 작동하는
Y의 측정이 존재해요. 이걸 어떻게 증명하는지 살펴볼게요.
편의를 위해 ρ라고 부를 X의 축소 상태에 대한 두 가지 다른 표현으로 시작해요.
그 다음 고전적 상태가 가능한 측정 결과들,
즉 볼록 조합에서의 인덱스들인 새 시스템 Z를 도입해요. 그러면 다음 두 양자 상태 벡터
γ₀과 γ₁이 복합 시스템 XYZ의 상태 벡터이고
둘 다 ρ의 정화임을 알 수 있어요. 분명히 하자면, 이 벡터들을 ρ의 정화로 생각할 때
Y와 Z를 함께 하나의 복합 시스템으로 생각하고, 그걸 추적 소거해서
ρ를 남기는 거예요. 첫 번째 벡터 γ₀은 새 시스템 Z를 영 상태로
초기화한다는 것 외에는 원래 순수 상태 |ψ⟩와 본질적으로 같아요. Y와 Z를 추적 소거하면 ρ가 남으므로 γ₀은
ρ의 정화예요. 두 번째 벡터 γ₁은 수업 앞에서 설명한 것처럼
볼록 조합을 기반으로 ρ를 정화해서 얻는 벡터예요. 이번에는 시스템 Y가
초기화되는데, 단순함을 위해 0이 Y의 고전적 상태라고 가정해요. 하지만 임의의
표준 기저 상태나 Y의 임의의 순수 상태를 이 표현에 대입해도 아무 차이가 없어요. 어쨌든 Y와 Z를
다시 추적 소거하면 ρ가 남아요. 결론은 이것들이 모두 ρ의 정화이고, 따라서
정화의 유니터리 동치성에 의해 γ₀을 γ₁으로 변환하는 쌍 YZ에 대한 유니터리 연산 U가 존재해요.
그게 정리가 말하는 걸 해주는 측정을 설명하는 데 필요한 전부예요.
간단한 설명 방법은 화면에 표시된 것처럼 circuit 다이어그램으로 나타내는 거예요. 말로 설명하면, 상태 F에서 시작해서 Z를 영 상태로 초기화하고 U를 수행한 다음, 최상위 시스템인 Z를
표준 기저 측정으로 측정해요.
사실 이렇게 하면 |φ⟩를 γ₁으로 변환하게 되고,
γ₁의 설명을 그냥 눈으로 봐도 정리가 말하는 것, 즉 각 결과 a를 확률 p_a로 얻고
a를 얻었을 때 조건부로 시스템 X가 상태 |ψ_a⟩에 남아 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
분명히 말하자면, 정리가 존재를 시사하는 측정 자체는 그림에서 점선 사각형 안의
모든 것으로 구현돼요. 그리고 측정이 행렬들의 모음으로
어떻게 설명되는지 알고 싶다면, 여기 그 표현이 있어요. 예제를 위해 이 부분을 설명하진 않을 거고 그렇게 중요하진 않지만,
관심 있으신 분들을 위해 측정 행렬의 표현이 여기 있어요.
다음으로 Fidelity를 다룰 건데, 이건 두 양자 상태가 얼마나 유사한지, 혹은 얼마나
겹치는지를 측정하는 값이에요. 정의부터 시작할 건데, 처음에는 좀 불가사의해 보일 수 있지만,
풀어서 설명하다 보면 논의가 끝날 때쯤엔 처음 봤을 때보다
훨씬 좋은 함수라는 걸 납득시킬 수 있으면 좋겠어요.
정의는 다음과 같아요. 두 밀도 행렬 ρ와 σ 사이의 Fidelity는 ρ의 제곱근 곱하기 σ 곱하기
ρ의 제곱근의 제곱근의 추적(trace)이에요. 이 정의의 의미부터 파악해 볼게요. 세 개의 제곱근이 있는데,
모두 양의 반정치(positive semi-definite) 행렬의 제곱근을 말해요. 이전 수업에서 논의했듯이, 이건
제곱하면 우리가 제곱근을 취하려는 행렬이 되는 유일한 양의 반정치 행렬이에요. ρ는
밀도 행렬이므로 양의 반정치여야 해서 제곱근을 취할 수 있어요. 그리고 ρ의 제곱근 곱하기 σ 곱하기
ρ의 제곱근을 잠깐 생각해 보면, 이것도 양의 반정치이고, 특히
σ의 제곱근 곱하기 ρ의 제곱근인 M에 대해 M†M으로 쓸 수 있어요. 따라서 제곱근을 취할 수 있어요.
특히 ρ의 제곱근 곱하기 σ 곱하기 ρ의 제곱근의 스펙트럼 분해를 계산하면,
제곱근을 취하기 위해서는 고유값의 제곱근만 취하고
고유 벡터는 그대로 두면 돼요. 그리고 마지막으로
이 행렬의 추적을 취하면, 추적이 고유값의 합과 같으므로
여기 있는 표현을 얻어요. 일반적으로 손으로 계산하고 싶지 않은 것이고, 이 설명이
Fidelity에 대한 통찰이나 왜 우리가 관심을 가지는지 별로 알려주지 않을 수도 있지만,
공식의 기술적 의미는 명확해졌으면 해요. 그런데 잠깐, 사람들이 때때로 Fidelity를
여기서 제가 정의한 함수의 제곱으로 정의하고, 이 함수를 루트
Fidelity라고 부르기도 해요. 두 가지 방식으로 정의하는 걸 보게 될 건데, 혼동을 일으킬 소지가 있지만 보통은 그렇지 않아요.
어떤 정의를 사용하는지 일반적으로 명확하게 하기 때문이에요. 여러분도
같이 해주셔야 해요. 솔직히 맞는 정의, 틀린 정의는 없어요.
이렇게 정의하는 건 단순히 이 방식에 익숙해졌기 때문이고, 조금 더 편리하다고 생각해요. 나중에 필요할 때 제곱근을 취하는 것보다
제곱하는 걸 선호하기 때문인 것 같은데, 물론
여러분의 선택은 자유예요.
어쨌든, 여기서 정의된 Fidelity로 돌아갈게요. Fidelity를 정의하는 다른 동치인 방법들이 있고,
그런 면에서 꽤 놀라운 함수예요. 꽤 흥미로운 방식으로 특징지을 수 있어요.
이전 수업 끝부분에서 봤던 추적 노름(trace norm)으로 정의를 다시 쓰는 꽤 직관적인 방법이 있어요.
추적 노름에 대해 너무 자세히 들어가지 않았고, 특히
비-Hermitian 행렬에 대해서는 정의조차 하지 않았는데, 충분히 간단한 정의가 있어요. 임의의 행렬의 추적 노름을 정의하는 한 가지 방법은
임의의 행렬 M에 대해 M 곱하기 M†의 제곱근의 추적이거나, 동치로 M† 곱하기 M의 제곱근의 추적이에요. 어느 쪽으로 해도 같은 값이 나오고,
그 정의를 사용해서 화면 아래에 있는 것처럼 Fidelity 정의를 단순화할 수 있어요.
좋은 건 두 인수가 대칭임을 보여준다는 거예요. 또한 정방 행렬 M의 추적 노름을
모든 유니터리 행렬 U에 걸친 M 곱하기 U의 추적의 절대값의 최댓값으로 표현할 수도 있어요. 자명하지 않지만
사실이고, 그러면 Fidelity에 대한 또 다른 표현을 얻게 돼요. 이제 Fidelity에 대한 세 가지
동치 정의가 있는데, 이건 시작에 불과해요. 다른 동치 정의들이 여러 개 더 있고,
수업 끝부분에서 Uhlmann의 정리에서 나오는 특히 중요한 것도 보게 될 거예요.
좋아요, 그게 다 좋은데 직관적인 수준에서 이 모든 게 뭘 의미하고 이 함수를 왜
신경 써야 하는 걸까요? 이 질문들에 답하기 위해, 두 밀도 행렬 중 적어도 하나가 순수 상태를 나타내는
특수한 경우를 생각해 보면 도움이 돼요. 두 상태가 모두 순수하다면,
Fidelity는 단순히 두 양자 상태 벡터 사이의 내적의 절대값이에요. 어떤 면에서는
이게 Fidelity 자체의 주요 동기예요. 두 양자 상태 벡터 사이의 내적의 절대값은
항상 0과 1 사이의 숫자이고, 두 양자 상태 벡터가 얼마나 겹치는지 측정하는 자연스러운 방법을 제공해요.
Fidelity를 순수 상태에서 밀도 행렬로 이 겹침 측정 방식을
확장하는 유용하고 잘 정의된 방법으로 생각할 수 있어요. 한 상태가 순수하고
다른 하나가 반드시 순수하지 않을 경우, 다시 Fidelity에 대한 간단한 표현이 있어요. 꽤
유용할 수 있고, 그 표현이 여기 있어요. Fidelity는 많은 흥미로운
성질들을 가지고 있고, 그게 사람들이 사용하는 이유 중 하나예요. 정의가 그렇게
좋지는 않지만 그럼에도 불구하고 매우 유용한 함수이고, 많은 놀라운 성질들 덕분에 사용하기가 자주 매우 쉬워요.
그 성질들 중 몇 가지를 살펴볼게요. 두 밀도 행렬 사이의 Fidelity는 항상
0과 1 사이의 숫자라는 관찰부터 시작할게요.
상태들이 직교할 때, 즉 이미지가 직교 부분 공간이거나 두 행렬의 곱이 0일 때만 0이에요.
그리고 두 밀도 행렬이 같을 때만 Fidelity가 1이에요. 다른 모든 경우는
그 사이 어딘가이지만, 직관적으로 Fidelity가 1에 가까울수록 상태들이 더 유사하거나
더 많이 겹치는 거예요. Fidelity는 대칭이기도 해요. 잠깐 전에 언급했는데,
추적 노름으로 표현한 Fidelity 표현에서 꽤 분명하지만, 그래도 인식하는 게 중요해요.
다음으로, Fidelity는 곱 상태에 대해 곱셈적이에요. 즉 두 곱 상태 사이의 Fidelity는
항상 개별 상태들 사이의 fidelity들의 곱과 같아요.
여기 정말 유용한 성질이 있어요. 같은 크기의 두 밀도 행렬이 있고
이 밀도 행렬을 입력으로 받는 임의의 채널이 있을 때, 그 채널을 두 상태 모두에 적용하면 Fidelity는
더 커질 수만 있어요. 즉, Fidelity 관점에서 채널은 상태들을
서로 더 유사하게만 만들 수 있고 덜 유사하게 만들 수 없어요. 그리고 마지막으로, 적어도 이 목록에서는,
Fidelity와 상태들 사이의 추적 거리(trace distance) 사이에 꽤 밀접한 관계가 있어요. 추적 거리는
두 밀도 행렬의 차이의 추적 노름의 절반으로 정의돼요.
두 상태 사이의 추적 거리는 상태들을 얼마나 잘 구별할 수 있는지와 강하게 연결되는데,
이전 수업에서 상태 식별 및 Helstrom-Holevo 정리 맥락에서 논의했어요. Fidelity는 두 상태가 얼마나
겹치는지 수치화해요. 그러니 정확히 같은 건 아니지만, 이 두
양 사이에 관계가 있다는 건 놀라운 일이 아니에요. 어쨌든 일반적으로 Fuchs-van de Graaf 부등식이라고 불리는
이 부등식들이 이 관계를 수학적으로 정확하게 만들어요. 그리고 여기서 우리가 얘기하는 시스템의 크기에 전혀
의존하지 않는다는 게 꽤 중요해요.
그림의 도움을 받으면 이 관계를 좀 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요. 두 상태가 있고
x축에 추적 거리를, y축에 Fidelity를 배치하면, 해당 수직 및 수평 선이 이 회색 영역
안 어딘가에서 교차해야 해요. 그래프에서 가장 흥미로운 영역은
적어도 실용적인 측면에서는 회색 영역의 왼쪽 상단 모서리예요. 특히 추적 거리가 매우 작을 때
Fidelity는 반드시 1에 매우 가까워야 하고, 그 반대도 마찬가지예요.
이 부등식들은 매우 자주 사용되는데, 그 이유 중 하나는 결국 추적 거리에 더 신경 쓰는 경우가 많기 때문이에요.
추적 거리는 양자 상태 식별과 연결되는 자연스러운 해석이 있기 때문이죠. 하지만 Fidelity는 너무 많은 놀라운 성질들을 가지고 있어서
일반적으로 더 쉽게 작업할 수 있고, 회색 영역의 왼쪽 상단 모서리에 있을 때,
그게 자주 있는 상황인데, Fidelity와 추적 거리 사이를 변환해도 많이 잃지 않아요. 그래서
이것들이 Fidelity의 일부 성질들이에요. 더 많이 있지만 좋은 시작이고, 목록이
Fidelity에 대한 직관을 기르는 데 도움이 되면 좋겠어요. Fidelity를 비파괴 측정과 연결하는
좋은 예제가 있어요. gentle measurement Lemma라고 알려진 아주 유용한 사실이에요.
시스템 x와 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 X의 상태, 그리고 양의 반정치 행렬들의 모음으로 설명되는 시스템 X에 대한 측정이 있다고 가정해요.
상태 ρ에서 측정을 수행하면 측정 결과 중 하나가 매우 높은 확률로 나타난다고 가정해요.
단순함을 위해 결과 Z가 매우 높은 확률로 나타난다고 가정하고, 특히 이 결과가
작은 값 ε에 대해 1-ε보다 큰 확률로 나타난다고 가정해요. 실제로 ε을 명시할 필요는 없어요.
ε은 그냥 작은 양의 실수예요. 이제 측정을 파괴적 측정처럼 설명했는데,
이전 수업에서 이 측정을 비파괴적인 방식으로 구현할 수 있다는 걸 알고 있어요. 특히
Naimark 정리 논의에서 봤던 것처럼 할 수 있어요.
각 결과 a가 P_a 곱하기 ρ의 추적과 같은 확률로 나타나고, 그 결과를 얻었을 때 조건부로 X의 상태가
변하는 방식으로 작동해요.
특히 결과 0을 얻는 경우, 상태는 √P₀ 곱하기 ρ 곱하기 √P₀의
밀도 행렬이 되도록 정규화된 거예요. gentle measurement Lemma가 알려주는 건, 이 이벤트에서,
즉 높은 확률의 측정 결과를 실제로 얻었을 때, 얻은 상태가 원래 상태에서
크게 변하지 않는다는 거예요. 특히 Fidelity의 제곱이 반드시 1 빼기
ε보다 크게 돼요. 이건 완전히 일반적이기 때문에 훌륭해요. 측정이나
상태에 대해 결과 중 하나가 매우 높은 확률로 나타난다는 것 외에는 아무것도 말하지 않았어요. 따라서 이 Lemma는
양자 상태를 크게 방해하지 않고 무언가를 확인하고 싶은 많은 다양한 상황에서 적용할 수 있어요. 이걸 어떻게 증명하는지 살펴볼게요.
대부분 사실 측정 전후 상태 사이의 Fidelity를 계산하는 꽤 간단한 일이에요.
원래 정의를 사용해서 할 수 있는데, 일반적으로는 지저분한 공식이 남을 수 있지만,
이 경우에는 운이 좋게도 외부 제곱근 안의 내용이 실제로 양의 반정치인 행렬의 제곱이어서
제곱을 계산하는 게 사소해져요. 이제 추적의 순환 성질과
추적의 선형성을 사용해서 화면에 표시된 것처럼 표현을 단순화할 수 있어요. 그런데 이것들은
모두 등식이라서 이 시점에서 아무것도 근사하지 않았어요. 그냥 단순화하는 거예요. 하지만 이제 부등식이 필요한데,
분자에 있는 제곱근을 없애고 싶고, 하한을 받아들인다면 실제로 그렇게 할 수 있어요. 이 부분의 세부 사항에 관심 있다면
P₀의 스펙트럼 분해를 고려해서 부등식을 꽤 쉽게 얻을 수 있어요.
P₀의 고유값은 0과 1 사이여야 해요. 측정을 설명하는 행렬에서는 항상 그래요.
그걸 알면 0과 1 사이의 수의 제곱근을 취하면 더 커질 수만 있다는 사실에서 부등식이 꽤 직접적으로 따라와요.
다르게 말하면, 0과 1 사이의 수를 제곱하면 더 작아질 수만 있어요. 이제 조금 더 단순화하면
P₀ 곱하기 ρ의 추적의 제곱근을 얻어요. 마지막으로
양변을 제곱하고 확률에 대한 하한을 대입하면 원하는 걸 얻을 수 있어요.
Fidelity 공식이 세상에서 가장 좋거나 사용하기 쉬운 공식은 아니지만, 여기서는 꽤
잘 작동해요. 수업을 마무리하면서 Uhlmann의 정리를 살펴볼 거예요. 이건 Fidelity에 관한 근본적인 사실로
정화의 개념과 연결해요. 이 정리가 간단히 말하는 건, 두 양자 상태 사이의 Fidelity가
그 상태들의 두 정화 사이의 내적의 절대값의 최댓값과 같다는 거예요.
좀 더 자세히 말하면, ρ와 σ가 어떤 시스템 X의 밀도 행렬이고, Y가
X만큼 많은 고전적 상태를 가진 시스템이라고 가정해요. 그러면 두 상태 모두 XY의 양자 상태 벡터인 정화를 가진다는 게 보장돼요.
그러면 화면에 표시된 방정식 형태로 정리의 시사점을 표현할 수 있어요.
ρ와 σ 사이의 Fidelity는 ρ와 σ를 각각 정화하는 모든 |φ⟩와 |ψ⟩에 걸친
|φ⟩와 |ψ⟩ 사이의 내적의 절대값의 최댓값이에요.
앞으로 정확한 수학적 문장으로 정리하고 작업해 볼게요. 이제 정리를 증명할 건데,
먼저 Fidelity에 대한 꽤 직관적인 사고방식을 제공한다는 걸 잠깐 음미해 볼게요.
또한 Fidelity에 대해 더 흥미로운 것들을 증명하는 데도 매우 유용해요.
증명하기 위해 밀도 행렬의 스펙트럼 분해부터 시작할 거예요.
놀라운 건 없어요. 스펙트럼 분해를 얻으면 이 상태들의 두 가지 특정 정화를 쉽게 구할 수 있어요.
하지만 여기서 실제로 트릭을 쓸 거예요.
두 경우 모두에서 수업 앞부분에서처럼 두 번째 텐서 인수로 표준 기저 벡터를 사용하지 않고,
첫 번째 텐서 인수와 같은 벡터의 막대(bar) 버전을 사용해요.
즉, 이 벡터들의 성분별 켤레 복소수를 사용하는 거예요. 다시 말해 기본적으로
고유 벡터의 두 번째 복사본을 가져오되, 각 성분의 켤레 복소수를 취해요. 왜 그렇게 하는지 잠시 후에 보게 될 건데,
이렇게 해야 한다는 게 전혀 자명하지 않아서 트릭이라고 부르는 거예요.
어쨌든 이것들은 각각 ρ와 σ의 정화이고, 고유 벡터들이 정규 직교하고
따라서 성분별 켤레 복소수도 정규 직교하기 때문에 그게 맞아요. 이제 정화의 유니터리 동치성을 적용할 수 있는데,
이건 두 상태의 모든 정화가 추적 소거되는 시스템에 유니터리 연산을 적용해서 얻어진다는 걸 말해요.
방금 선택한 특정 정화에 대해, 두 정화에 대한 유니터리 연산이
같을 필요는 없어요.
그래서 여기서는 첫 번째 것에는 U를, 두 번째 것에는
V를 사용해요. 요점은 두 상태의 모든 정화가 화면에 있는 것처럼
유니터리 연산 U와 V의 어떤 선택에 대해 쓸 수 있다는 거예요. 이제 정리에서 표현을 가져와서
단순화할 수 있어요. |φ⟩와 |ψ⟩에 대한 표현을 대입하고 조금 단순화하면
화면에 표시된 표현을 얻어요. 거기에 몇 가지 단계가 있고 세부 사항은 보여주지 않았으니
어떻게 할지 아시겠죠. 그런데 이 방식으로 정화를 선택한 이유는
내적이 정확히 이런 방식으로 단순화될 수 있게 하기 위해서예요. 특히 켤레 복소수를
넣은 건 두 번째 텐서 인수에서 내적을 효과적으로 뒤집어서
여기에 있는 특정 형태를 얻기 위해서예요. 거의 다 왔어요. 이제 추적의 순환 성질과
시작했던 스펙트럼 분해를 사용해서 이 표현을 얻을 수 있어요. 이 시점에서
추적 노름을 사용하는 Fidelity 표현의 대안적 방식 중 하나를 활용할 수 있어요.
그러면 완성돼요. 물론 거기서 매우 빠르게 지나간 세부 사항들이 있고,
완전히 이해하려면 직접 풀어봐야 하는 종류의 증명이에요. 하지만 기본적인
아이디어는 전달됐으면 해요. 언제나처럼 수업의 글로 된 자료에서 더 자세한 내용을 찾을 수 있고, 링크는 영상
설명에 있어요. 이것으로 정화, Fidelity 및 그 사이의 연결에 대한 수업이 끝났어요.
양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화를 다뤘던 단원의 마지막이기도 해요. 시리즈의
네 번째이자 마지막 단원인 양자 오류 수정 단원에서도 함께해 주시길 바라요. 시청해 주셔서 감사해요.